plan vite dans croquettes du just
finished fois où kiev
gérard voilà tu au zoom dessus pendant
ce temps là michel donc tu as dit
décidément la chance vous lâche
décidément voir la chose moulage mai
prochain coup au prochain tour je sens
que je vais me repère j'ai un peu la
pression d'être faible encore à faire à
l'opus ça c'est de bonne guerre que je
dis je le savais mais c'est très très
passionnant à faire mais c'est très
difficile et fatiguant je n'aurais pas
expliqué pourquoi parce que voir même
temps ce chien est merveilleux il joue
c'est extraordinaire en même temps je
m'attends merveilleusement bien avec des
vides barclays marionnettiste anglais on
s'entend très bien et en même temps j'ai
quand même pas du tout les mêmes
rapports que si c'était
à l'acteur et des scènes au cinéma où
c'est un peu comme quand on joue avec
agossou avec un véritable animal
tu suis la taille qu'un peu moins de
vent la voix demande à voir une grande
pour sa marionnette à la télévision je
trouve pour wigan et je dois de voir que
j'aimerais bien qu'en france on voit des
marionnettes de cette qualité c'est
d'ailleurs relativement intéressant pour
fr3 puisque nous avons à cette occasion
tu re découvrir les compétences de deux
marionnettistes français celui qui
s'occupe de la marionnette travelling
maths et de gobo qui est jean-pierre du
tout et nancy qui avait eu des jumeaux
et artistes du chien croquettes
ne serrez pas de forcer le hasard
monsieur croquer ou ou et savez vous
qu'au refus aux tricheurs dans l'ouest
le lointain
on les couvre de goudron et de plumes
[Musique]